meeting with the prime minister today
what do you think it could achieve
well what the prime minister wants to do
is to listen to fans listen to those
people who have a real
interest in football and are passionate
about football
and outline his clear view that this is
a super
league that must be stopped because it's
just simply not fair
it's not right football is rooted in the
communities and
clubs have grown up in and um you know
it's there for the fans it's there to be
uh you know
part of that community and this super
league looks as if it would
really destroy that but also the key
core element of football which is
competition
because as we uh watch the premiership
it's not
just a battle for the top it's also a
battle for survival at the bottom
and this seems to have been dreamed up
by
money men as against something for
football fans and that's why
the prime minister is so opposed to it
and yeah yeah you will have heard in our
report that fiontino perez
saying that this is about saving
football
well in fairness he was bound to say
that wasn't he
and um what we are wanting to do is to
put the interests of
fans right at the heart of this but the
interests of a
whole uh game of football at the heart
of this and that's not something that
these proposals for a european super
league is doing
uh it's ignoring communities it's
ignoring
uh the competition that exists in the
game of football
and that's why the culture secretary
yesterday
and the house of commons made it
absolutely clear the steps that the
government is going to be taking
to ensure that uh this is stopped we're
going to be putting
uh all our support behind the football
association and uefa
in terms of their steps that they may
need to take but if they're not
successful in doing that
the culture secretary has been
absolutely clear that we won't hesitate
to take
further steps in order to ensure that
this european super league
won't go ahead well he wasn't clear
though was he when he's
speaking yesterday oliver dowden said
the government will do whatever it takes
to stop the league
well what can the government actually do
well um oliver's uh dowden the culture
secretary
set out a number of steps the first step
of that is actually working with the faa
and uefa
in order to find a solution within the
football family and obviously that's the
preferred option
and we'd hope that these clubs step back
from the proposals that they have put
forward
if that's something that isn't going to
happen um
the culture secretary made it absolutely
clear in the house of commons that
we'd look at every single option in
order to stop this moving forward and
we are we're focusing uh on the initial
stages in supporting bfa
supporting uefa to stop this going ahead
but you cannot be clearer
the culture secretary couldn't have been
clearer about the government's
commitment to ensure that this doesn't
proceed
including the announcement of uh tracy
crouch leading the fan-based review
yeah but with all due respect i mean
look a lot of football fans will be
pleased to hear you say what you've said
but it doesn't
it still leaves that very big question
what in reality can the government do
yes you you you've got the tracy crouch
review yes you're talking to
the fa and fans representatives today
but in actual solid terms
you know these these are ultimately
private businesses can you
actually intervene in any way
well the government of course can
intervene and the government has made it
clear that we
would be willing to intervene if a
solution isn't being able to be found
between vfa and uefa well our first
initial efforts have got to be
supporting the faa and supporting uefa
to find a solution to this and make sure
that the
european super league doesn't go ahead
but if that
doesn't uh come about if we're not able
to stop it through those means
the government reserves its position in
order to take further action
in order to stop this european super
league it's just simply not right for
football
football is about bringing people
together yeah it's the first give me
foreign absolutely will take action
such as well the government reserves
this position to take any action that's
required
including the need to take legislation
the need to take
sanctions in order to ensure that we
protect football interests in this
country and that's the right approach to
do
but the the first most important step is
to ensure
that we put our full support behind the
football association who is equally
opposed to this and we saw
uh prince prince william voicing his
concerns uh
last night about this and uh the
government is right to be fully
supporting the fa
in its opposition and trying to find a
solution to this
what we would encourage is all of these
six clubs to step back
it's not in the spirit of football it's
not what the
um it's not what fans want you've heard
it it's not what players want it's not
what managers want
um it seems to be what the money men
want and that isn't what should be
driving football
okay so what sort of sanctions are
available to government
well a whole range of sanctions but as i
stated the first step is
to support vfa and support uefa uh in
order to be able to
give you i mean minister with the
greatest of respect and i apologize for
for interrupting
um you've you've said what the first
steps are we're clear on that you said
there are
you know a range of sanctions available
again such as
i mean what realistically can you do
well the government is willing to sort
of review all aspects it's willing to be
able to look at
what further sanctions and impositions
that he can put on clubs
it could look at legislative options as
well but
we focus very much on the first stage
and the first step but
in reserve there is the option for the
government to take further action
and of course we have got the fan base
review that uh tracy crouch is going to
be leading
there's going to be making sure that we
take the steps that are required
in order to be able to protect the
interests of fans
in football can we have a look at the
the covid situation
if you would obviously we had the news
yesterday that india's going on to the
red list
already what we think about 303 known
cases of the indian variant
in the uk which is a double mutation
which causes some concern
um have we left it too long to put india
on the red list
and and if not why are we leaving it
till four o'clock
friday morning before that actually
happens
well it's as you all know it's standard
practice to give people a sort of short
window in order to be able to
uh manage their affairs it's the right
approach to do it's the approach that we
take them with other countries around
the world when they've gone on to the
red list
the government continuously reviews the
data
continues continuously reviews the
information that we're getting from the
scientific community
um in terms of what countries should be
entering
being put onto the red list and sadly
india has been one of those countries
that's had to be added
i mean how concerned are you and your
colleagues and sage as far as you know
about that about the indian variant and
and the effectiveness of our vaccine
program against it
well we've seen an enormous success in
terms of our vaccine program
leading the world in the rolled out of
our
vaccines whether that's the oxford
astrazeneca
fisa vaccine right across the country
and it gives us a level of protection
that few and other countries are
able to sort of rival but we have to
remain vigilant we have to remain
vigilant against new variants
that's why we've had to place india on
that red list
and it's the fact that we always take
these matters seriously that we've taken
the action and the steps to place
india onto that red list i mean there is
some concern that the the
indian variant has had a bit of a surge
since schools reopened that's according
to
uh professor pagle from the sage group i
mean again we've got to
look very carefully at this we all seem
to have a mindset don't we that we are
on this real path to easing things up
and it would seem
we've still got to be very careful well
as
we've seen when schools returned on the
8th of march we saw
children going back to school safely and
securely you saw
one of the largest mass testing programs
that we created
for school children right across the
country with tens of millions of tests
being
conducted making sure that children
and also ultimately their families and
for
the school and the community are
properly protected by having this mass
testing regime
and we haven't seen a spike despite some
people
um you know uh raising concerns that
that would be a the case
but that's because of responsible
attitude that children have shown
families have shown uh but also um
you know sort of teachers have led the
way in terms of ensuring that uh
children have been able to return to
school safely and i think it's something
that we're
very proud of that uh all children have
been back in school for
uh over a month now since uh the eighth
of march and been benefiting from being
back in school
um the prime minister is today expected
to try to push our
our climate credentials even higher is
we think he's going to talk about
britain cutting carbon emissions by
78 compared to 1990 levels by
just 20 35 that is ramping things up
impressive in many respects and lots of
people are asking how can we actually
achieve that
well the prime minister has always been
clear that britain is going to be a
global leader
we were the first country to enshrine in
lore our commitment to getting to net
zero
uh we recognize that there's significant
challenges with that and there's going
to be significant investment and the
government's already
outlined significant investment that's
going into
um into our battle to ensure that we get
to net zero
but it's also about ensuring we have the
right skills in our economy
and that's why i'm incredibly proud
today to be able to announce the fact
that we're introducing
flexible apprenticeships we're going to
ensure that
young people and people of all ages are
able to
take part in an apprenticeship
especially in some
sectors and parts of the economy that
maybe aren't able to
usually be able to take on
apprenticeships such as the
creative industries such as construction
and
including new emerging environmental
businesses that are taking advantage of
a new green economy
is making sure that uh you know we
create
the skills for uh to be able to feed the
jobs revolution that will come out of
this
uh you know commitment to generating uh
you know
a green economy that's able to service a
net zero
country